i haven't taken one phone call today
isn't that something
it's been a very full show let's go to
paul paul is in charlotte north carolina
uh listen one of my favorite parts of
the show is when you say something
that's so funny that's right just cracks
up in the background you kind of hear
him tackle
do you notice that do you like that does
that give you a sense of pride
no i don't like it i i don't feel fred's
uh laugh is real
that's your opinion yeah i think it's
fake laugh okay oh i think it's genuine
do you think he has a real laugh robin
or is it fake be honest he has a real
laugh
i do a lot of times for some reason
you've got it in your brain
and i can't change that whatever
whatever bug is in your brain
it's eating into it i love telling
friends
just love the irritating friend yeah i
don't like when he laughs it's fake
no because just it's just crazy i think
fred does have a real laugh but we've
never heard you've never heard it yeah
he's a tough audience very good would
you admit what
that sometimes you do put it on a little
bit no
you won't no that's a real laugh let me
just bend you benji you sit right next
to him do you think he's sometimes fake
laughs well i
i that has been my sincere thought that
you have i've said that before
however if you're saying you're not i
will believe you
but that would be
for some reason this is a big source of
controversy no i want to note
that my laugh has been very well
received
as a very genuine i wasn't talking about
joking about it
wow we i'm talking about fred and he
goes right to his life right now she
sucks the attention on him
yeah so i wouldn't have that fred that
was your moment and benji tried to take
it
hey howard can i tell you why i think
the laugh is real go ahead
if you play back the show he does laugh
at the funniest moments
yeah no he he's trying to be human
it's like frankenstein like you mean he
doesn't know how
yeah when he hears something he does it
but it's not real that's my
opinion i'm not putting fred down it's
like when uh they were trying to teach
data a sense of humor yeah right like
the guy on um star trek
yeah data he's like mr data right he's
like an adaptive learner
right like like oh fred there's people
laughing now go laugh
so you can't hear me you can't hear me
laugh right now but i am lying
mr data
no i'm just saying fred and i don't mean
it as a put down i think i
admire fred trying to fit in okay i do
even some of his anger is fake oh yes
because he's just trying to be emotional
oh okay
dude this is really just crazy talk this
morning no big deal you're like you're
like that vulcan
and it goes overboard sometimes the
anger because he doesn't really have the
right
oh now you're joining into that thank
you for the right formula
yeah let me adjust my anger hasn't
gotten it
the two horses have hooked up and now
they're pulling the wagon his name isn't
even fred
how you doing fred you want to tell
anybody anything personal
or you want to have a moment where you
have the microphone i think this was the
moment that was right about whether your
laugh is real
i believe that fred thinks his laugh is
real
oh so he's not lying no he's not a liar
he's an honest guy he just
but it's not a real laugh i don't know
how you would be more
i'm just very keyed into fred do you
hear it all the time uh-huh
i sometimes even lower his mind you've
got problems then yeah i know
you lower his mic yeah because it's so
loud it like
it's like
i don't even know what you're talking
about yes you do of course you do
but fred's my man and i let him do his
thing that's it i appreciate it i
appreciate that when you're not busy
trying to
beat me down into not laughing all right
anyway enough of that we had enough fred
let's cut your mic off